I think the vast majority of Voters
don't agree with the Democrats framing
of any of this and if you actually look
at you know who voters Trust on various
issues like restoring faith in democracy
isn't actually an issue that Democrats
lead on funny enough despite all them
talking about restoring democracy and
stopping Donald Trump from you know
subverting the election and yada yada
all this stuff you know Republicans
actually lead on issues surrounding the
election and securing the election and
all those sorts of things so it's it's
it I think it's going to fall on deaf
ears and I think the reason why they're
pushing that message so hard is they
don't have anything else to run on what
are they going to say we pass the
inflate inflation reduction act that
didn't reduce inflation like they don't
I mean that's the thing is their entire
premise in this election cycle you know
there's about six weeks left all they
have left to do is to try and distract
voters because every day every American
feel this economy is getting worse crime
is going up the border is very clearly
not secure